you know it was uh it was one year ago
this week
and we spoke on the telephone Mr
President
it was very late at night in Washington
very early in the morning here in Kiev
Russian planes were in the air and tanks
were rolling across your border
you told me
that you could hear the explosions in
the background
I'll never forget that
and the world was about to change
I remembered vividly
because I asked you I asked you next
I asked you what is there Mr President
what can I do for you
how can I be of help
and I don't know they remember what you
said to me but you said and I quote
gather the leaders of the world
ask them
to Port Ukraine
gather the leaders of the world
and ask them to support Ukraine
and you said that you didn't know one
would be able to speak again
that dark night
one year ago
the world was literally at the time
bracing for the fall of Keith
seems like a lot longer ago than a year
but think back to that year
perhaps even the end of Ukraine
you know one year later Keith stands
and Ukraine stands
democracy stands
the American stands with you and the
world stands with you
Keith has captured a part of my heart I
must say
I've come here six times as vice
president
wants his president
and in 2009 as vice president when I
first came here
then back in 2014 I came three times in
the aftermath of the revolution of
dignity
and I again came in 2015.
to address the Rada
about the work of building a strong
democracy
and I came in 2017.
just before I left office as vice
president
I knew I'd be back but I wanted to be
sure
even though we the election were over
Barack and I were out of office
I decided to make one more trip
before the next president was sworn in
to Kiev
so president zielinski you deeply
honored me
here in key with you today
to meet with your military your
intelligence folks your diplomatic teams
Community leaders who have stepped up
and helped their country
in their hour of need as astounding who
stood up everybody
everybody
women
young children
trying to do something with this trying
to do something
pulling people out of apartments and
being shelved and literally I think is a
war crimes
it's astounding
in the whole world
the whole world
sees it
and looks at it
this is the largest land war in Europe
and three quarters of a century
and you're succeeding
against all and every expectation except
your own
we have every confidence that you're
going to continue to prevail
you know
from the moment I first received an
intelligence report in the fall
about a year ago
we were focused on determining
how do we rally the rest of the world
how do I help you with the promise you
asked me to make to Rally the world
well how do you succeed
how to get a world to respond
to a prosperous economy a confident
democracy
a secure and independent state
when United Americans of all political
backgrounds decided that they would
step up
American people know it matters
unchecked aggression
is a threat to all of us
we build a coalition of nations from the
Atlantic to the Pacific
NATO
to the in the Atlantic Japan and the
Pacific I mean across the across the
world
the number of nations that have over 50.
help Ukraine defend itself unprecedented
military economic and humanitarian
support
we United the leading economies of the
world to impose unprecedented costs
that are squeezing Russia's economic
lifelines
together we've committed nearly 700
tanks
and thousands of armored vehicles
one thousand artillery systems
more than two million rounds of
artillery ammunition
more than 50 Advanced launch rocket
systems anti-ship and air defense
systems
all defend you to defend Ukraine and
that doesn't count
the other half a billion dollars were
going to be we're announcing with you
today and tomorrow
that's going to be coming your way
and that's just the United States in
this piece
and just today
that announcement includes artillery
ammunition for high Mars and howitzers
more javelins anti-armor systems air
surveillance Radars they'll protect
Ukrainian people from Aero bombardments
later this week we will announce
additional sanctions
against Elites and companies that are
trying to evade sanctions and backfill
Russia's War Machine
and thanks to bipartisan support in
Congress
this week we are delivering billions in
direct budgetary support
billions in direct budgetary support
which the government can put to use
immediately and help provide for basic
Services of citizens
the cost that Ukraine has had to bear
has been extraordinarily High
and the sacrifices
have been far too great they've been met
with them in far too great
we mourn alongside the families of those
who've been lost to the brutal and
unjust War
we know that they'll be very difficult
days and weeks and years ahead
but Russia's aim was to wipe Ukraine off
the map
Putin's war of Conquest is failing
Russia's military has lost half its
territory it once occupied
young talented Russians are fleeing are
the tens of thousands not wanting to
come back to Russia
not not just fleeing from the military
fleeing from Russia itself
because they see no future in their
country
Russia's economy is now a Backwater
isolated and struggling
Putin thought Ukraine was weak
and the West Was divided
as you know Mr President I said to you
in the beginning he's counting on us
not sticking together
he was counting on inability to keep
NATO United
is counting us not to be able to bring
in others
on the side of Ukraine
he thought he could Outlast us
I don't think he's thinking that right
now
God knows what he's thinking I don't
think he's thinking that
but he's just been plain wrong
plain wrong